it's kind of funny that it's called
Dinner for Schmucks and the dinners just
one small part of the movie I mean they
should have called the movie me and my
schmuck or something that'd have been
better
[Music]
in either case Dinner for Schmucks no
Dinner for Schmucks had its ups and
downs most things do and is it gonna be
a classic probably not but it was pretty
funny so the story goes Paul Rudd works
for Christopher Pike from Star Trek and
in order for Paul Rudd to get that
promotion that he's always wanted at his
job he needs to find an absolute idiot
and then bring him to a dinner where
other people bring their absolute idiots
and they all laugh at the expense of the
poor idiots douchebags enter the idiot a
role that Steve Carell plays very well
and then after they meet we watch Steve
Carell and Paul Rudd bond or Steve
Carell annoys and destroys Paul Rudd's
entire life but isn't that what bonding
is now I will definitely say that
everybody in this movie played their
roles perfectly Paul Rudd and Steve
Carell were the perfect contrast for
each other as a normal guy who just
wants to get ahead of his job and the
most oblivious that I have ever
seen ever like I said he does it very
well and that guy from Flight of the
Conchords is a crazy narcissistic artist
Captain Pike is the corporate douchebag
I'm always gonna call him Captain Pike
that one girl who looks a lot like
Alexis Arquette is that crazy unstable
stalker chick and Zach Galifianakis is
indeed a creepy little man and this all
mixes for some really funny moments and
also some very uncomfortable ones I mean
I felt really sorry for Steve Carell is
character in this movie it's almost
uncomfortable and painful in parts but
uncomfortably funny is pretty much what
this movie is all about the funniest
scenes in this movie are also the most
uncomfortable one scene in particular I
was just like oh god I can't watch
uncomfortable yet funny it kind of
reminded me of what about Bob I always
loved what about Bob my friends were
always like no I can't stand what about
Bob because of Bob if I ever knew
someone like Bob I swear to god I would
kill him now I was always like all right
debbie downer but after this movie I
kind of understand where they're coming
from there are scenes where you just
want to kill Steve Carell there are but
you're supposed to feel that way so the
movie does do its job and some scenarios
felt for us one scene in particular I
swear to god the writers were like
alright here it is so how do we get Paul
Rudd and Steve Carell in the same place
at one time
ah well give Paul Rudd a back problem
then Paul Rudd will throw out his back
and Steve Carell will have to drive him
there they both there at the same time I
like it yeah but we'll have to give Paul
Rudd a back problem and he'll have a
back problem through the whole movie and
we'll just do it for that one scene then
we'll never touch on it again perfect
we'll do it I just hate it when things
fill for us I mean it didn't bring down
the whole moon
just an annoyance so Dinner for Schmucks
wasn't the funniest movie of this year
by any means but it was entertaining and
it succeeded at uncomfortably funny if
I'm comfortably funny is your thing and
your Steve Carell fan who really likes
what about Bob I think this movie might
have been made for you by the end of the
movie it has a good lesson to it and
even though Steve Carell has annoyed you
every bit as much as he did Paul Rudd's
character you really do feel for the guy
and you really like him and you hate
Captain Pike to use it is definitely the
best comedy that's in theaters right now
at this moment even funnier than eclipse
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more well here you
go just for you
[Music]